left-hander tarik school bullies making
his 28th start of the season he's faced
the royals
five times in his career including three
as a starter
uh he's got 16 starts in his career
against the american league central
teams
rolled over to short on the charts took
a weird hop but a nice play by harold
castro you bet what a recovery by harold
castro
another test for castro and another nice
play
[Music]
another 3-2 to perez struck him out
there's newton 200 in terrex scuba's
and he does it in terms of appearances
faster than any other tiger we'll head
to the home half of the first after that
and now they'll see
jonathan heasley who is making his
second big league start
that is into the right field corner and
dozier has room right in front of the 3
30 mark
one away
[Applause]
and that fastball got in on scope
nikki lopez back pedals to the green
grass and there are two down
it's up way up
after a good start
[Applause]
[Music]
makes a nice running play to give
heasley a one two three bottom of the
first miguel cabrera leads off
second inning
six up six down for tariffs google
rather impressively ground ball base it
up the middle for miguel cabrera
first pitch fastball turned it right
around sharp singleton to center field
you love it every hit he gets means
something
no castro at the plate
there's the curve
lopez
merrifield
santana for the double play
[Applause]
beautifully done
jack's one to deep left field badou's
going back he leaps got it he's got it
oh what a grab by akil badu
duju dozier is stunned and badou with a
huge smile on his face
and a high five and a heavy applause
from the hometown faithful edward
olivares was called up again yesterday
they've been careful with their innings
and pitch count olivares gets it over
the shortstop castro and that's the
royals first base runner to lead off the
third now the tigers bad in their half
of the third isak paredes
nikki lopez dives he throws from a knee
on a bounce
are you kidding
oh man just add another play to that
long highlight reel this season in 2021
that ball was smoked
here's uh
carlos santana leading off the kansas
city fifth early this year
3-2
fastball up and away
carl santana leads the fifth off with a
walk
and now here's that alberto monteci
so when he gets away from garneau
santana moves up to second takes a wide
turn
and then
jogs back to the bag
and now monday's thinking about getting
the runner over
i think he wanted to bunt that by the
mound for a base hit
so he'll take a sacrifice one three
with hunter dozier in the box
and into right field
grossman
looked like he lost the ball for a
moment and that took all of his forward
momentum away he was lucky to hang on to
it
and dozier comes through with a
sacrifice fly and the royals lead one
nothing in the fifth
first pitch to harold castro misses the
mark ball one
castro down the left field line ben and
tindy cruising over and that ball
bounces it's a fair ball and into the
stands it's a ground to rule double for
harold castro with one out here in the
fifth
[Applause]
garno fouled out his first time up
line to left field ben intended is there
and for a second straight night
a young royal starter begins with five
scoreless innings
jonathan scope stands in
scope got jammed get in floater left
field
that drops badou all the way to third
and he is
safe at third base
they've got word
they're gonna call him out
stay there scopey
[Music]
and miguel cabrera coming up here
and cabrera singled back in the second
bounced into a double play his last time
up
cabrera to right feet down the line
dozier dives it's off his glove scope
will score
grossman is rounding third he's being
waved home throw to the plate not in
time miguel cabrera comes through with a
clutch two out two run double and the
tigers have the lead
candelario deep left center field that
ball is at the base of the wall
cabrera trots home candelario's got his
league leading double number 42
and it makes it 3-1 tigers
well they've solved domingo tapia
here
in this game in this half inning again
ben and tindy he has grounded out to the
third baseman candelario twice
then attendee has tried to go that way
twice but unfortunately hit it right at
candelario both times and now he gets it
over candelario catch that and a good
start for the royals after
falling behind last half inning kyle
funkhouser is in for the tigers here
with two away and a man aboard here in
the seventh trying to hold it right here
at 3-1 tigers
dozier lines it into left field
monteci will make the turn
he will go to third as a throw goes to
second and dozier is going to be in
there with a hustling double
yeah because now he's in scoring
position he represents the tying run
to center field badu back pedals he's
got it
made it interesting
but funkhouser leaves a couple of men in
scoring position to keep it 3-1 this guy
runs so well
that the ground ball infield double play
is going to have to be hit on a line
in order to turn it got two really good
speed runners at first with merrifield
and lopez at the plate
lopez grounds it into right field
that will get whit to third nicki's
digging for second
and the royals have runners at second
and third with one out and salvador
perez coming up yeah maybe our bat boy
can distract uh sal perez there 3-2
the payoff
he got him looking
back up slider
what a pitch
to michael fulmer
you know it's funny because aj makes a
move here right you got runners at
second and third
and he's feeling better that that uh
michael former stuff is better on this
situation you've got a guy that came
into the series red hot and andrew
benatini at the plate
the one-two sits him
down michael former comes in and does
exactly what his manager was hoping he
would do mickey comes up base has loaded
nobody out here
back up the
middle one run is home
here comes scope miguel cabrera delivers
again
tyler up from double a the manager of
the sea wolves ground ball to second
tigers will win it that's a good one too
5-1 on the strength of miguel cabrera's
three-hit 4 rbi night